ну ви знаєте я тут у нову схему
розмовляв про відносну можливість
лівія богатирським розбавляв у чадо може
влади обміну надій савченко вам знову
матриця який точно я заруби
виставка ще процес триває дуже важко
процесів йде в перших дуже важко те
є одна акція на проблемах та його c
проблема кремля
цьому трохи йому сенсі кремль на перед
шитою готовністю я не може сказати
ще дві сторони Москви готовий вниз до
обміну е.а.
ян шоу ви вирішення ситуації з українською
іполит узником і фактично заручником і
в Росії про крем ок обмін на весну і
вогонь крім обміну і немає положення
суду Росії як би це робить
російські суд епохи дні авторитарну
влади людей звикай до кут він світло
людей фрики вайда кримінальну вигляд і
дальності та зсадять не наситили закон
краще права, а через політичну з
вавеля іра неприємний механізми до ідеї в
Росії в репресивний механізм
діє в основному у
пропагандистські суди та суд савченко я з
ліжка купить вірджинія за процесом а
листочки
там не максу, а листочки там не йдеться
ви знаєте я їхню душу я думаю їх і поміняю
типу porsche така практика вже
тусувалася як старкова офіцера
російської армії завтра іманова на
території України на донбасі та
заслуженому на 14 рокер обміняла на
рахмана офіцер вибраних сил україни топ
то сам по собі такий механізм проти
під інші процесуальні можливості
ось так вже коштуватиме європейська
конвенція про видачу права вітрильники на
дозорі а вид provide with blood і
покарання савченко після ви руку з
виношування і вид видно присвоєння
рядок наказання в Україні а єрофєєва та
Олександрова
легше води будуть за суди не судом
україні вид протезів це москви
виду а ти поки що раніше в росію з чоловіком і
механізм обміну та жодних порошків для
чого знімаємо обміну практика
обміну тобто і перешкоджає у них для
цього нема на де можна весь попит і ти
помив його не алі потребою пороху не
падала сама савченко
а вона видна вляется swore to the сяду
путі цьому в силу протесту саме на
день вікторини з механізм малоймовірні
надії віктора влаштував цю тіні коняку
сяяла і україна мус від висоти надю
савченко на жаль і зміцнюватися готовий
готова то люди ніч живота і ви з
хитрого ти взято на собі ту гілку і
дальність якова та створила yet знає ще
не зможете ви кімнати аджита сторона т
знаючи з черги дена не сидітиму і там у
в моєму явно не верхову трохи всю
ситуацію можна пити на пузику
декларативні зуба в'язання які ви
розбираєтеся в ікону, а ти так і акції
свобод шас азру було москва
я канікули на обиралася цю трубу від
себе будапештському меморандуму його коли
на нього підписував а он ще
гарантувала територіальну
цілісність України то мою тему випадок
кримінальний вид правої ти додому
авс та інша з технічнішою деталі я все ж
питання щодо контактних осіб ким ви
стикалися про пиво хто думаю ви вирішите
частку наді та повідомив чи організації я до
жаль вогонь ну звичайно ж це все з
особливим і скидав той дружина президента
порошенко хтось
з верховної ради різанини люди різні люди
ну знову ж таки сама по собі сама аполітична
влада ук або спрею та захисту савчин шо
ми відриваємо від документи з б розум
отримуємо заспівав про в'язницю і полон і дуже
текучою служити з нас консульським
департаментом мізків у крилами тобто ще
більше коло уколу людей нас правді ту ж
велика проста на запитала воші можемо
волосся називати їх ними треба це не мати
навіщо ви думаєте, що це і ціни моя
значенням і непотрібно до висоти нашої
думку допишу і особливо
яко пряме рішення і під блазень і купа шлях
у різну інформацію ще до перспектив
обміну немає жодної інформації щодо
перспектив
робити я Миколу Микула Полозів поважаємо
ася великими його рогами так я як ми
беремо вкрасти у всіх політичних
процесах або справа того, чим і
і на її пориви вірні камін адвокати не
беруть він функцію
моє завдання меншому там ще процесі до
їжі в донецьк качки так висоти а був
сторони я до нас ага це повернуто і
савченко було великим вузли його варте
більше дивідендів
щоб пара канати банановим на
вона не винна лише на обмін
вигляд будете нас кликається справа голову
двох російських планами їх мене ти на
одного українського
віджавши руси ще й від мінімум 10 на законі
за наречених українців ще не логічно
тут краще пару туссена логічно тут
коротше друг з компроміс свобод шансу
солдата армії оборони ізраїлю гілада
шаліта
обміняла на 1027 палестинських повітових
синій солдат офіцера
tennis патріота вона вище 6 рівна так
ревність патріот вона вища
чисті арифметики